THINKING THAT AT TIMES IS
DISRUPTIVE THAT WE NEED
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION
IS NEWT GINGRICH, FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE AND A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
NEWT, IT'S SO GOOD TO HAVE
YOU BACK FROM ROME.
HOW ARE YOU?
ARE YOU PERPETUALLY JET
LAGD?
THAT'S MY QUESTION TO YOU.
>> NO, NO.
IT'S FUN.
>> Laura: LET'S TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO,
THE USUAL SUSPECT, YOU KNOW
ALL OF THEM.
YOU SAW THAT TEDIOUS
MONTAGE.
TRUMP IS NOT SMART.
HE IS DUMB.
CETERA.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
>> I MEAN THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN PASSIONATELY
AVOIDING REALITY FOR THREE
YEARS ARE NOW ENTERING A NEW
YEAR PASSIONATELY AVOIDING
REALITY.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS A WHOLE
SERIES OF THESE THINGS WHERE
I'M WORKING ON A BOOK RIGHT
NOW CALLED "TRUMP'S
AMERICA."
THERE IS A WHOLE CHAPTER OF
HOW WRONG THEY ARE.
WHETHER IT'S SOMEBODY SAYING
HE COULDN'T POSSIBLY BE
ELECTED, A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO SAID THE STOCK MARKET IS
GOING TO CRASH THE MINUTE IS
HE SWORN.
IN YOU GO BACK AND YOU PICK
THESE PEOPLE UP.
I HAVE A STANDARD RULE.
IF I LOOK AT THE SUNDAY
MORNING SHOWS AND ALL OF THE
WONDERFUL ELITE WASHINGTON
FIGURES HAVE AGREED THAT THE
SKY IS GOING TO BE BLUE.
MY ASSUMPTION IMMEDIATELY IS
IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY ARE
WRONG SO OFTEN.
LET'S TAKE A CASE OF THE
CURRENT.
THERE
TIGER WOODS CADDIE ACTUALLY
THOUGHT HE MADE THE PUTTS
AND FORGOT THAT IN FACT IT
>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT
BANNON THOUGHT THAT HE HAD
THE SKILLS THAT TRUMP HAS.
>> Laura: HE MIGHT RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
REPORTS THAT HE COULD BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> HE WILL GET 3%.
I THINK ACTUALLY THIS
EXPERIENCE PROBABLY
SENATOR FOR TEXAS SAID THE
FALLING OUT FOR BANNON MAY
BE A GOOD THING FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WHAT I'M WORRIED IS THE
RICOCHET THING.
BANNON IS A CONSERVATIVE
POPULIST.
I AGREE WITH HIM ON ALMOST
IS HE A STUDENT OF HISTORY.
YOUR HONOR WHAT'S BEHIND
THESE QUOTES.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET INTO
THAT I DON'T WANT TRUMP TO
TAKE THE BANNON PROBLEM AND
TAKE THE LESSON FROM THAT
BEING I'M NOT GOING TO DO
THESE ISSUES THAT, YOU KNOW
THAT WE AGREED ON TOGETHER.
I THINK THEY ARE -- THEY
WERE GOOD TOGETHER.
I'M NOT SAYING BANNON WAS
TRUMP.
TRUMP, TRUMP.
THEY WERE GOOD TOGETHER.
>> FIRST OF ALL I THINK
STEVE MILLER.
>> Laura: I'M TRYING TO MEND
FENCES FOR PEOPLE.
>> GOOD LUCK.
>> Laura: WELL, WHAT CAN I
DO?
MILLER IS THE HEART OF.
>> Laura: LOVE HIM.
DOWNSIDE.
>> Laura: QUIET.
>> HE IS THERE DOING HIS JOB
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I HAVE THINK HE PROBABLY
CHANNELS TRUMP BETTER THAN
ANYBODY IN THE COUNTRY.
SECOND, I ACTUALLY HAVE --
THIS IS LIKE REAGAN.
GOING TO LUNCH AND HERITAGE
GOING OH MY GOD REAGAN IS
SELLING US OUT.
I HAVE ENORMOUS FAITH REAGAN
IS REAGAN AND TRUMP IS
HE BELIEVES IN DEREGULATION
AND CUTTING TAXES.
STAYS.
>> Laura: SESSIONS A COUPLE
CONGRESSMAN, MEADOWS AND
JORDAN SAYS SESSIONS SHOULD
PROBABLY STEP ASIDE.
MIGHT BE TIME FOR HIM TO
STEP ASIDE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT?
>> I THINK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS OUGHT TO
HAVE A VERY SERIOUS REVIEW
OF WHAT HE IS DOING.
HE HAS A DEPARTMENT THAT HAS
AS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND I LIKE JEFF A LOT.
AND.
>> Laura: ME TOO.
>> I HOPE HE WILL DECIDE
THAT HE IS GOING TO CLEAN
HOUSE AND GET THE JOB DONE.
>> Laura: THEY ARE OPENING
WE WILL SEE.
YOU ON.
GIVE MY BEST TO YOUR -- DO
YOU CALL HER AMBASSADOR OR
AMBASSADORRESS.
>> SHE PREFERS YOU CALL HER